[Music]
life is imitating art Jennifer Lawrence
is officially a married woman that is
true yes the oscar-winning actress tied
the knot with her love of more than a
year gallerist cook Maroney was great I
couldn't be happier the pair have made
it a point to keep their relationship
out of the public eye rarely being
photographed or attending public events
together you know despite the couple
keeping a low profile
Jayla couldn't help but gush about her
bow to ET in June why is cook the one
why is he the one that made you say
uh-oh
throwing that away well he's just the
best person I've ever met in my whole
life it was it was a very easy easy
decision and shortly after that Lawrence
also opened up to pal Catt Sadler about
her upcoming nuptials on her naked
podcast I definitely wasn't at a place
where I was like I'm ready to get
married I just met cook and I and I
wanted to marry him I we wanted to marry
each other we wanted to commit fully and
you know I want to he's my best friend
so I have when I want to legally bind
him to me forever
so unfortunately the paperwork exists
for such a thing it's the greatest are
you nervous about your wedding day no
not really I'm kind of I've been in a
good place I haven't been like neurotic
about it I'm a little I'm like too lazy
to be neurotic I like saw dress I liked
I was like that's the dress I saw it
Venu is a cool we got the venue I feel
very honored to become Moroni
[Applause]
[Music]